I were talking a little bit about your
history with Anton Ryan you guys both
worked on Half Nelson which was 2007
Desmond we shot it in 2005 it would came
out in 2006 okay I want to talk a little
bit about how they approach storytelling
you guys are producing partners they are
filmmaking partners let's talk first of
all how they approach material this is a
story that I think they developed while
they were working on the film sugar is
that right well they in inspirations for
this were definitely from sugar and
spending time in Iowa and and
particularly the riverboat casinos and
and sort of observing that they're there
they got their roots and in film school
but also in documentary films and so
they're very they're very observational
and like to tell stories of what they
see so so sugar is where the sort of the
genesis of the idea came from and what
do they bring to you and at what point
do you guys get involved is there a
screenplays their cast how far along are
this one was right at the very very
beginning this was this is an idea we
were actually working on another script
with them that we were trying to put
together that was you know sort of
stopping and starting and trying to get
cast and cats would fall out and and in
the sort of the frustration of doing
that they wanted to do something that
was a lot smaller and a lot simpler than
what this ended up being which was let's
just do it two-hander about these two
guys that go down the mississippi and
play poker and and and they pitched this
to us and and it was loose it was
basically gonna be a very loose kind of
outline and then we were going to em
they're going to improvise the rest of
the screenplay so that's kind of how it
started and then they went on a research
trip and and then slowly the screenplay
started to develop and then as the
screenplay became fully formed they
worked on it more and worked on it more
and then it became an actual fully
formed screenplay was there a line item
the budget for gambling losses do they
actually go or that was that the actress
responsibility it was the actors
responsibility but it was definitely it
was definitely up for discussion at one
point but I think back to Lynette said I
don't know exactly what Ronnie and would
say but if someone said you know here's
a bag of cash
make your movie I'm not sure they would
have written the script they probably
would have said let's take ryan reynolds
in bed metals and let's get in the car
let's have a 15 pass follow us and let's
see where it goes they probably would
have written it out and written the
day's scenes ahead of time but they
probably would have not shared a full
script but unfortunately that's not
exactly how the world asta can finance
it works but how do you I mean that's
poses a very interesting question
because they have their style they have
their way of working you have your style
your way of working and their dream has
to meet the reality of financing so at
what point you say I love the idea of
we're going to go down the road and just
got to make it up as we go along but
that's not going to work in this world
and here's where we can meet halfway
what are those conversations like Lynn
it I mean I think that I think you know
it comes down to what you you know what
tools you need and the people that you
need and you know a lot of the crew they
work with some of the same crew over and
over again and they're definitely you
know in it with them and will will will
go to war for them but at the same time
you know we made have we made half
nelson for you know under a million
dollars and a lot of that crew was up on
coming at that time and now those that
crew is you know ten years later they
earn more money and and you know there's
just a cost to wanting to shoot on film
and there's a cost to certain actors
this is a cost to this and at a certain
point you say no one's going to give you
the money that's required to make the
movie you want to make in the way that
you want to make it without a screenplay
and that's really where it came down to
was that you know if we could have made
the movie for half a million dollars and
just got in the car then that's one
thing but that's that wasn't the reality
of the resources that they need and they
don't need a lot they're not there
certainly by you know by any means
gratuitous in what they and what they
require for their movies far from it but
it still was enough in this day and age
with this kind of story that there
needed to be more of a blueprint Kenneth
and I think that some extent happens
probably in every film a definitely
every independent film is that it in the
way Lynette and I work as producers it's
all about choices for the filmmaker
and it happened on this film and it's
saying till Annette's point okay well if
you want to do the film in this way and
over this amount of time this is what
it's going to cost it's going to take
for that version of the film this is
what comes with it you know we had the
same experience on Blue Valentine which
we produce together you're Derek
Cianfrance at one point want to take six
years off between the past Blue
Valentine the present and then he wanted
to take six months off and then he
wanted to take three me a boyhood maybe
we should have done that but then he
wanted to take three months off and then
you're trying to convince the bond
company in the financier that it's put
all these people on hold for three
months it's critical to the film and you
know and finally you know he won with
you know what you got one month in the
end and that's probably he wanted from
the start he just said he watched in it
now but it's the same it's the same
thing in every film and those
conversations are tough and they're
never fun when you're trying to give you
know as we work we're trying to give our
filmmakers every tool they can have to
make their movie and you just have to
balance it this is obviously a fictional
film but that has a lot of
verisimilitude and I'm going to talk
about a couple different elements let's
talk about locations about actually
getting in casinos riverboat casinos big
casinos the negotiations that you have
as filmmakers with those casinos how
willing or unwilling are they to let you
film there and what are the
conversations that you have that
persuade the right people to give you
the access you need it was it was a lot
more challenging than we thought partly
because you know you've seen so many
casino films where there's violence and
drugs and prostitution and they'd shot a
real casino so we didn't really cross
our mind well if they've done that
that's horse neighs it can do it why
can't wait yeah well if we're just you
know we're just shooting guys playing
cars we're not really doing anything
else how challenging it would be and and
it became you know the most challenging
part of making the film and what's
getting those all kashien locations some
of them were easier than others some of
them were were accommodating and but
even when we were accommodating this the
location still run by the state Gaming
Board you know so we want to use a
specific slot machine and
it well you can't just move a slot
machine you know state game works come
in to move a slot machine so it's the
challenge is you only shoot at certain
times of day and usually at night and
really late one night yeah so you have a
lot of shoot days that are you know
eight pm to five a.m. or six a.m. was
there objection to what the script said
I mean was that I mean if they're
willing to let the hangover shoot in a
bit cuz you know what did they say
specifically about this movie that they
objected to I think the reality of it I
think that it felt very real and it felt
like the part of gambling that they
don't want shown you know it's not the
people might lose hangover is all fun
and games and bravado and this is very
real they don't want to see people who
are losing their homes or losing their
their families they want to see people
who are high rolling and having fun and
having a party that's does that's what
happened yet every Cambria is